thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
constantin lupulescu
after a very tense and exciting game
constantine first of all
for all the commentators we want to
congratulate you because
you decided not to make it roy you
decided to play you showed spirit the
type of spirit that we're trying to see
in this type of tournaments
thank you thank you i somehow i felt
maybe i'm slightly better but
i couldn't find i couldn't fight how did
you pick this opening uh
you lost against grishok in this opening
we were expecting something more on the
lines of let's say a french something a
bit more reactionary how did you
choose this one yeah like with the
french i said okay second time should be
a charm so
i said okay i lost in french then i made
made it work
the second time also here yeah everybody
was being hitting my
if my uh with e4 against my opponents
for some
reason and then okay i said i could make
it work
and then tomorrow was no no was taking
his time in the opening so let's go
through the
game yeah so all the time he's taking
his time okay i thought
he will be in prep a 4b5 bishop f6 gf6
king b1
queen b6 knight c2 yeah and here um
actually i looked this position some
time ago i couldn't really remember
exactly what i'm doing
because actually he wants to play f5
sometimes
and then i can transpose to the main
line in a bad version
maybe i was considering some
some we're getting some severe alerts
sorry about that guys
severe weather alert maybe long castle
okay before
i thought it's not so bad i i thought
should be okay imagine i see it
disagrees
okay and then f5 i thought i think it
was just an accuracy because
okay if he just plays nice bishop c6f5
of course we get
transposed to the grish2 game but this
gives me
extra options because now i can take on
d4 take one d4
e5 and now it's not clear where he's
going because
knight e2 now it's not so good anymore
because h5
and he's not really in time h4 i can
play king e7 then bishop
yeah i'm more than fine so knight f3
yeah here i was getting optimistic
because i didn't really
see how this knight is going to play of
course
h5 was very tempting uh you need to
somehow get it back to d5 but that's a
long road from
now yeah yeah i also thought bishop c6
but i didn't like
bishop c4 idea bishop b4
bishop d5 bishop takes queen takes
rook c8 92 quincy six ninety four
yeah i thought okay at least black is
not better i thought
even though this knight could
potentially be kicked out via rook j
rook g4
yeah yeah yeah yeah somehow i didn't
want to allow this
and yeah i thought the bishop on d5 it
will not be so impressive just by itself
so i played h5 to secure my bishop a6 in
the long run
bishop c4 rook c8
yeah queen h5 i think he has
many ways to play but again the question
is
if he can get the knight into play or
not sometimes uh
too many ways to play yeah in this
position queen d5 queen e2
queen d3 basically you have to choose
where to put the queen
yeah somehow i thought i'm just fine
here i see okay engine disagrees but no
he seems to have played
it quite okay so 25 7
92 yeah here of course i wanted to play
fastly
some um what what i want to play
some a5 ah a5 maybe but then the problem
is bishop e2
and then knight c4 and he comes and
finally the
knight is useful so
yeah so i did bishop c6 queen d3
a5 bishop d5
it felt like he was slowly slowly
pushing the pieces where they are
supposed to be and then he just decides
to go for this draw
like the knight coming to c4 felt uh at
least
the right direction and queen c5 and
b3 yeah but here i also thought this
it's
playable for me i have some a4 this
bishop on h6 will be a strong piece
i think it's totally unclear perhaps
perhaps
during the game he felt maybe he's bit
short on time i don't know
exactly yeah so bishop okay so bishop d5
bishop b5 bishop c4 i said why not
bishop d7
and see how it goes on okay g1
a4 all the commentaries were definitely
commending you for this decision
to just uh not repeat the position maybe
i was a bit optimistic but
i i thought i'm just i'm just fine so
knight f1 okay what the ah
a4 actually because if i play uh what
did i want to play
yeah k7 my problem was bishop b3
and then if a4 knight c4 queen a6
knight d6 queen d3 and just knights see
it let's say bishop c
rook d3 i was afraid the same game can
be bad so that looks like it
yeah so that's why i went a4 and then
knight f1
okay here bishop h6 is forced
b3 stop the knight from yeah okay
yeah typical and okay of course k7 it's
also normal
we need to
yeah h for here okay
if i'll give gives him some time then
he'll arrange his pieces and then his
bishop on c4 will be much stronger
than my bishop on d7 double up on the d
yeah try to put some pressure
no counter plates doesn't look uh yeah
so this was
this was the right moment to swap i
think and here
i was bit optimistic because he was also
very short on time i think he got to the
last seconds at some point but last four
seconds before
he played the move g4 i think at move 34
yeah
it could be he was short on time but
very strange moment at least from our
part yeah okay i think it was i think it
was good practical decision actually
because otherwise what she should do
no it was the best move in the position
i mean at some point he needs some
counter play
and then after g4 hd hgt hg3 rook g7
queenie tour of g8 g4 understood okay
suddenly things are not so simple
because
if i move with the rook to c8 then he
already can play some g5 ideas
and if i could swap the queens i could
play on this endgame but it's not
working so okay here i decided
it's enough enough it's time to replace
yeah it's just time to repeat
we're getting close to the end of the
event how do you feel about your
performance
up to this point i think it's been going
going uh good
i mean there were two games where i
didn't
actually get to play against fabiano and
against
alexander kischuk i i mean
the point the problem was losing that
way but apart from that
i feel good thank you very much for
joining us lupu and we're looking
forward to see you
tomorrow thank you goodbye guys back to
you
thank you